[Applaudissements]
sasa pont vers le score demain moi je
vous le dis à mon avis ça va pas ça va
pas faire mon 3g en prime je pense à
carlo non vous nous raconter votre
histoire tout à l'heure pour l'instant
on va accueillir qu'un banal c'est
franck dubosc qui sont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc
[Applaudissements]
durée toi c'est magnifique ce tout à
fait c'est mythique je ne sais pas mais
c'est en d2 mais c'est bagics savamment
et tu aimes pas comme ça franchement ces
bases ne vieillit pas quoi ça va très
mal
[Applaudissements]
les spectateurs on s'était lancé un défi
froch m'avait dit tu auras les cheveux
blancs et fois qu'il veut juste avoir la
barbe mais comme ça mais écrivent aussi
et moi je les fais là-bas mais comme ça
30 18 mois a poussé tout j'adore comme
ça franck dubosc et valérie soir
[Applaudissements]